hello everyone welcome back to the lobby
gamespot's weekly hang out I'm like my
hardy Daniel Dwyer still doing his thing
over in Europe again I don't know where
he is somewhere over across the pond
somewhere weird like that i don't know
international never been there i will be
soon though yeah Gregor I've been
telling you about this I get to go work
from our UK office for about a week
before I go to games com yeah first time
yeah lucky guy yeah Scott Butterworth
you'll be at Gamescom I will be a saw I
was gonna make fun of the Nerds I'm
gonna be there too yeah it doesn't this
really work sorry so I can make fun of
both you come yeah yeah I'll go see our
UK team hang out with them for a while
see what's up over there I don't know
what happens over there I think they use
different money than us pretty sure yeah
there's something about their leaving
something and some some guy do thing
yeah we'll figure it out we're not in
the best political situation either I
know yeah yeah all right on a more on a
lighter note i guess we have a giveaway
today we have yarny he's uh this guy the
platformer game which came out a few
months ago we also have codes for the
game he also has a tail here you can get
we're doing a giveaway at two-fifteen
gamespot will send out a tweet about
yani itself and just basically all you
have to do for a chance to win is
retweet it and also i kind of recommend
telling us whether you would want it for
xbox one or ps4 x we have codes for both
so yeah I'll get back to that again at
the end of the show but here he is he's
adorable and affable as ever I don't I
don't see it I just he's kind of creepy
to me if he had a mouth maybe be better
I'm kidding just retweet you'll have a
chance to get these the game as well
which is always great I'm gonna get yarn
you away from mic yes I feeling creeped
out we will get back to that but right
now let's get to the show Jake Decker
you played telltale Batman telltale the
Batman series realm of shadows the fact
that I'm in the taupe ulcers realm of
shadows I did I played it so did two
more yeahh two more Hussein over in the
UK reviewed it gave it at eight liked a
lot but you played it yesterday right I
played it yesterday I think he liked it
more than I did I'm i think i'm a little
more burnt out on the telltale games
than he is though mm-hmm and i might
crash like six times while playing it so
on pc other people try it out to more
than have any issues Joey tried it out
have any issues but for some reason
maybe was just the pc configuration just
it crashed six times so that kind of
ruined my experience but I mean it's a
typical telltale first episode it's good
if you like Batman you're gonna like it
yeah I remember you just said you were
saying you kind of tired of telltale
games which is where I'm at and I want
to bring scones I know you play a lot
he's get I I was never super into those
kind of games to begin with I recognize
their like writing quality and their
narrative strengths and kind of you know
the illusion of choice they give you and
I really like walking dead season one
the wolf among us i also finished that
um but for Batman what's like if you're
a Batman fan is there a lot to like here
if you're not just like a Telltale Games
fan yeah I think Batman fans are really
gonna like it it tells i'm not i'm not
super familiar with the comics I've seen
the movies and it tells somewhat of a
different story one thing that two more
pointed out was that it tells like the
stories trying to break Bruce Wayne
rather than the Batman so instead of
like putting Batman through the wringer
it's more about putting Bruce Bruce
Wayne through the ringer and there's
like a lot of crap happens to him this
game and it'll be really interesting to
see where it goes from there mm-hmm and
this does set up all that pretty nicely
but I mean if you want like a it's not
all it's not action packed though at
least not yet like there's not a whole
lot of like Batman beating up thugs it's
still there but it's not as prevalent is
maybe some people hoped easy for those
games is always kind of liked or sorry
the action for those games always kind
of like q te heavy right and it is for
this too and like one thing that's kind
of weird I don't remember it being like
this in the walking dead or wolf among
us but when one weird thing is that like
you can straight-up just not hit buttons
and just play through it and then if you
don't hit enough of them after a while a
guy'll dislike shoot you or something
we'll be like the end but Batman will
still like beat the snot out of people
you know if you don't hit anything so
it's not like he's actually messing
things up it's kind of weird I came over
and saw you like just like leaning back
in your seat kind of like every once in
a while when you're prompted just
pressing the e key to shoot your back it
just look over ticularly engaged so that
was like my third time playing through
that parts that may have been why I
looked pretty uninterested but he did
look very good but yeah like it sounds
like it's kind of delivering what we
want from a telltale Game right that
narrative I don't know Scott you're you
have you played like all
Telltale's properties by this point I
don't think I think I played all of them
because they've been making games for a
long time but I've been keeping up
pretty closely since the first season
the walking dead like seasons one and
two the walking dead wolf among us I
didn't ever finish Game of Thrones but
tells in Borderlands when my favorite
games from last year and yeah it's
they're not they are not mechanic Evie
games if you are looking for action you
are absolutely in the wrong place and it
sounds like Batman's approach which I
have not had a chance to play yet
unfortunately but it sounds like the
approach that take to action is similar
to but not exactly like their previous
games you're right that in improving
seems you actually have to like hit
buttons or you would fail like if you
missed one or two button presses like
the you know you would die or something
bad would happen it would kick you back
to the beginning of the section so it
sounds like you can kind of get away
with a little bit more here but um two
more actually pointing this out in his
in his review that it wouldn't really
fit the character if he was just getting
beat up by regular old thugs right so it
was kind of a weird line for a telltale
to walk like it wouldn't make sense for
him to just be like missing punches and
getting worked over by thugs just
because you missed a button prompt so I
can kind of see how they were caught in
a tricky situation there but then again
like maybe they just should skip over
this action stuff all together like if
it's if it's still not really that
engaging if it's still just quick time
events and people really aren't that
into it maybe they need to really just
recognize where their skills lie
continue to focus and invest more in the
storytelling and the decision-making and
less on the QTEs it'll be interesting to
see how they sort of like evolve their
approach to combat for Batman over the
course of the series but there's a
chance that it won't change at all
honestly I'm a lot more interested in a
walking dead season 3 that seems like
that might change things a lot more but
that's not that's not for a few more
months till yeah that's the thing every
time they announce a new property which
I feel like they have a lot now Batman
was the first one was like what are they
doing but that doesn't seem like the
Lego stuff or not the Lego The Game of
Thrones stuff the wolf among us that
made sense like I what was the minecraft
minecraft maybe that sorry not Lego yeah
my story mode yeah which they're not bad
that older qu so I just don't this seems
like my initial impression when I first
sorta lies properties that are forcing
these narratives on things I wouldn't
want a narrative and like walking that
makes sense it's a like a
post-apocalyptic zombie world we've
become accustomed to that kind of trope
by now wolf among us same thing based on
the graphic novel
fables fable i'm not mistaken but then
Game of Thrones comes along but Batman
that's the one that I actually that's
the one I'm most drawn to I love Game of
Thrones but I want to give in to Batman
like you said they're kind of like
trying to put Bruce Wayne through the
wringer and I really like that idea of
after a while is Batman really the mask
or is that the real one and then Bruce
Wayne is the actual character do they
really set up any like kind of cool
character studies in this game or like
threads they're gonna extend through
with what five episodes I'm assuming
yeah i think is your typical five
episodes but yeah they do so they do
like i said they do set up Bruce Wayne
an interesting way in Batman is kind of
just there to beat up beat up thugs like
when Bruce Wayne can't do something it's
like all right Batman and then you do
quick time events which actually you can
you can't fail them if that wasn't clear
it's just like it's very lenient but
then there's also a new character well
not a new character he's uh he's people
know him I don't want to spoil it but
they introduce him in a very different
way which is also something that two
more mentioned in his review which I
think could be really interesting later
down the line or it could just fall flat
as if now is pretty interesting and then
you know you've got your typical
characters like Selina Kyle Catwoman
that kind of play like very similar to
what you'd expect but once again like I
feel like they are planting seeds to do
something more with these characters
which is interesting I think Batman fans
are really gonna like it do they push
the detective angle and investigating
because I feel like that that was that
um they used it for Rocksteady's games
and that made that was some cool like
fun ways like you know described them as
the greatest detective in the world or
whatever do they do that with the
telltale games I feel like that like
tailor made for this kind of slower pace
they do and I think that's probably like
the most successful parts when you're
Batman they're still relatively simple
like you're not gonna get stuck on one
of these for a while but it's like it
you'll go into a room and there'll be
all this like evidence laying around and
basically you need to connect different
pieces of evidence to each other and
then like a sort of I forget what it's
called but like a holographic recreation
will play it out for Batman and the
viewer and you can kind of like see like
okay this is what's going on it's
actually pretty gory to like some of
these crime scenes well you only
investigate one but the one you
investigate is it's pretty gory like
this is a mature mature Batman story if
people
interested do they kind of they've
mentioned the multiplayer did you get to
try that at all or is that like you did
try it can you try me try just talking
laughter is not encouraging no can you
how does it tell tale game first off
like just describe it to us because I
really don't even know how a telltale
Game would have multiplayer so you know
like jack box TV so it's similar to that
and that you get a code you go to a
website on your phone and then you enter
the code give yourself a name and then
you can vote on things to say and then
when there's nothing to say you can
either thumbs up or thumbs down the
scene I don't know we didn't quite
figure that out you just thumbs up and
thumbs downing random stuff but
basically whenever there's a dialogue
choice everyone in the room can pick
like what choice they want to say from
their phone and the Batman will say it
and yes I was a majority rule or is it
just like somebody who's driving we'll
we'll look and see what's when Jordy
rule really so Alex thought he was
testing out with me and he thought that
I still got to pick because I was mouse
and keyboard turns out though like we
had three people vote for one thing and
I voted for the other and that one went
with it so it is democratic really just
that because that that's really
interesting that it like if you commit
to having other people with you that
they are like they are in your game they
are taking control you are really in it
together yeah I would just be one of
those people trying to derail the entire
thing not to just be control but like I
don't if it's a democratic thing I just
want to actually try to upset the
balance i guess i guess i am gonna watch
the zone well like i just thought i
wasn't a chiral and i define myself i
think yeah but yeah but the problem with
it though is that well i mean like if
you did something like this what would
you typically want to do with this like
streaming right mm-hmm you can't stream
it though because decisions you have
about eight seconds and that lags not
gonna quick enough yeah so i mean the
the easy thing would be just to get rid
of the timer mm-hmm but for some reason
they didn't do that so you can't really
stream this you have to like have a
separate stream for the decisions and
then like a delayed one for the actual
choices yeah see that's already too much
work no one's gonna do this but telltale
said that they are trying to figure out
a way so people can stream it just kind
of a shame that they haven't figured
that out because that seems like the
main appeal for something like yes like
I'm not gonna invite my friends
over in like let's watch Batman telltale
as we pick to sit like I don't know just
make sense yeah I don't know I I don't I
like Batman a lot like a lot of people
do nowadays but I don't know that a lot
of times a telltale games I have nothing
against them they're just I think
they're very well written I think like I
said I like that the choice is carried
through to the end I like the episodic
structure I think it works well here I
just always feel like I could get that
experience from another medium I don't
know like I like narrative games you
know like everybody on the rapture gone
home i think if they're done well they
can they can achieve like really
impactful messages and stories but i'm
just wondering if it's enough to put me
in as a Batman fan and if you're a
telltale fan whether that'll pull you in
as well I'm kind of wondering if they're
balancing those two camps well I mean I
think if you're a Batman Finn you're
definitely gonna want to play this I was
actually talking to one of my good
friends he loves Batman and he's he's
absolutely in love with this like he
thinks it's fantastic um if you're a
telltale fan you're probably gonna be
sick of this formula by now I think it
sounds like it doesn't really change all
that much like people who know telltale
games were gonna just like yep it's
another like just iteration of that same
formula which you know again I mean I'm
a tell stofan obviously and even I'm
like okay this is starting to wear thin
like we really need some new ideas which
again is why I'm excited about walking
dead season 3 but as people have sex
it's become almost like a rallying cry
for people who aren't big on telltale
games that the end is the same no matter
what choices you make and that's true
for basically every single telltale Game
look no matter what choices you Nick no
matter how the path branches you
ultimately end up with the same
destination and yeah they've got to
start doing things a little bit
different or even yet telltale fans are
just gonna get totally burnt out on it
and maybe you're not meant to play every
single telltale Game maybe it's like all
your Batman fan play this one like oh
your kid left my craft play this one you
know if you're playing every single one
you'll get burned out much more quickly
very fast but still even even if you're
just picking and choosing the ones you
play it's like it really couldn't hurt
for them to update the way they do
things it's great though the writing
maybe yeah Scott regardless of your
current backlog of games do you plan on
playing this uh I mean I would love to
someday but it's definitely not top of
the list for me like I like Batman but
I'm by no means like a hardcore Batman
fan
and I've played a lot of telltale games
like and I have so much other stuff to
get through yeah like I saw I saw him
play doom I really want to play doom for
example like just this may in particular
this year there were so many big
releases that this one is like I'll play
it someday like it would be on Steam
sale something like oh god never play
Batman I'll totally play it because I
love telltale and I'm sure enjoy it sure
but yeah there's nothing about this
particular series that has me like
really thrilled and excited yeah well
anyway I think I'm sort of borderline I
don't think I'll get to any time soon
like like you Scott or Jake I don't know
to endlessly more positive note i will
say that i love that they are focusing
on Batman or on a Bruce Wayne I love
that there's like political intrigue
that it's not just about Batman that it
is about the full character I think that
was a really genius choice so if there
if there is a reason play this game
that's it yeah I mean judging by reviews
of Suicide Squad d seniors can take any
help they can get so uh but anyway yeah
that is telltale the Batman's Batman the
tell-tale series episode one realm of
shadows you can check out tomorrow saenz
review on gamespot even an eight out of
ten he really liked it tell us what you
think are you interested for more
telltale games you interested for this
specific one walking dead season 3 like
Scott said leave your comments in the
section below on YouTube or gamespot and
tell us what you think all right on to
the next section Scott another game
that's like not really a game quote
unquote but one that I think all three
of us were really positive on as well as
Pete Mary pretty much took the game spot
office like by a stealthy storm we're
talking about ABS ooh yeah so this
wonder a lot of people's radar so before
we get into your opinion about in your
review which or their sonar nice Oh was
trying to set up a scholar point
wouldn't this is a class yeah help
myself I'm a terrible human you all hate
me now anyway it wasn't like I've seen
like in the comments echo the dolphin
jokes yeah even though it's not a
dolphin it's not anything like echo the
dolphin is just under water but anyway
so tell us like what abs you is in a
nutshell if you can sure so it's
basically it's an underwater exploration
game it's very much like journey so
there's no dialogue that the characters
don't really have names there's no even
real context it's just you sort of wake
up in the middle of the ocean and you
begin your forward journey it's it's a
very linear experience but you're also
can kinda
explores your own pace for the majority
of the game so you can really enjoy the
sea life that's all very believable like
all of the the ecosystems you interact
with their like happening around you and
and just kind of subsist without you
even influencing them it's just you can
watch and enjoy all the stuff happening
around you it's a very like I think the
way I put in my reviews it's a very
profoundly peaceful experience but there
is more of a story the more you play you
start to uncover different aspects of
the world and you realize there is kind
of that everything you want covers
alluding to this sort of narrative and
the more you play the more you
understand so it actually becomes a
really moving and and like just kind of
timeless experience and it goes in some
really surprising directions it evolves
in ways that I really didn't see coming
and I and that's really all I want to
say about it it's one of those really
difficult to discuss games because it is
relatively short I only took me about
four hours and I was really taking my
time so the more you talk about it the
more you risk kind of spoiling the
enjoyment but I'm spice to say it is
more than an ocean life simulator even
if it really is is a really great ocean
life simulator for a lot of the
experience yeah it's weird because even
though there are kind of spoilers even
like talking to other people the office
is kind of hard to describe like what
the spoilers are it's a very kind of
like it's it's like you compared it the
journey a lot could you talk about that
like the comparisons with that or yeah
totally um people who have been reading
previous of the games probably know that
this this game was actually made by
journeys art director it's a new studio
giant squid but it's several team
members from who worked on either
journey or flower of uterine games of
that kind of ilk somehow imposer as well
Austin wintery yeah on music is really
fantastic can get into that because I
was a big partier of you as well yeah
for sure um but yes I mean like I said
the it doesn't it doesn't have journeys
multiplayer which is a bit of a shame I
mean I think part of what made journeys
such a powerful experience for most
players was that that moment of walking
up to another character in the world
realizing that it's another human and
and you can't actually speak to each
other but you can still kind of
communicate like that was such an
original and interesting idea and and so
powerful in the context of that world
where you did feel kind of isolated and
lonely so this game does not have
multiplayer but it kind of fills that
void in a different way and and like I
was describing earlier its share
is a lot of just structural similarities
to journey in that just linear it is
brief it is wordless it is primarily
about exploration it's relatively light
on mechanics so there's no there's no
combat you can't be actually died in the
game I mean I actually tried I messed
around to see if like I could find a way
to fail and you you really can't but
that I think just speaks to the type of
experience it is it's kind of like a
beautiful and meditative experience more
so than like a traditional you know
video game in in like the Mario or you
know shooter sense or anything like that
yeah you kind of touched on it but I'm
there a couple times throughout it when
I thought I was like it's lurking into
the territory i feel like it just trying
to gamify things whether it's through
like puzzles or like collectibles but it
never was too difficult or too kind of
clawing that I got in the way of the
experience it was trying to be I found I
liked it just for like how peaceful and
like Zen it is and totally like when
they first announced I thought it was
just like a scuba diving diving
simulator before I really looked into
who it was and what not not like a
hardcore simulator but like I have a lot
of background scuba diving oddly enough
and so I yeah I just like this setting
like the setting and like itself is
initially appealing but you know you
start getting too though you start
discovering new creatures like you know
like these different barracuda or I
don't know if these are actual like real
I don't think these are scientifically
um I think they are too to a degree i
mean like so you want one of the
mechanics and games you can sort of
cling to larger animals and slide around
on them and when you do like their name
will appear in the bottom right corner
and it's you know it's not like they're
latin scientific genius you know yes
your sperm but yeah it'll tell you what
the animal is and it seems like they
went to some effort to ensure that the
animals looked and behaved in ways that
correlated with the real animal so yeah
I mean I don't know that this is gonna
be like an educational tool it's not
quite at that level but certainly it
seems like they paid attention to the
species they were including what they
look like and how they act and how they
interact so to some extent I think it is
like somewhat scientifically accurate I
don't know that that was like yeah maybe
not as far as you'll find like this kind
of orca whale alongside an angler fish
at this depth or anything yeah it does
if they are like the artwork itself is
very despite the fact like I think you
call it winwaker
ask it's also very that they are like
their detailed creatures despite the
fact that it's kind of a minimalistic
look um but also you know like it is
tough to talk about because you can't
get into like who you are or like what
like what is going on at all whether
there is something going on which is
frustrating but yeah right but it's it's
also like I guess like the number one
thing for me I was worried about ever
since like games became 3d swimming has
been one of games big problems so before
like I heard you and Pete come in after
you had reviewed NP had played it as
well I was worried as saying I don't
want to devote two hours or however long
it is to like struggling with swimming
controls but it turns out that's not a
problem here no not at all the swimming
pool is fantastic like better than
probably any 3d game that I can remember
and I think a lot of that can be
attributed to the control scheme which
actually is very close like a racing
games control scheme when you think
about it it's sort of odd but but it
works makes perfect sense you're you're
using our to like the right trigger to
swim forward so matter which direction
the cameras facing if you hold our to
your character just swims forward which
is great because that lets you kind of
look around and enjoy the environment
and then use the left stick to sort of
change direction and the animation is so
fluid but you will just kind of flip or
twist in whatever way and it looks
really graceful and it always is very
responsive to your input so the swimming
ends up feeling really fantastic again
probably better than any game that I can
remember mm-hmm and then you throw in
like the boost mechanic where you have
to kind of like rhythmically tap the X
button to build up boost and like just
that can be really exhilarating kind of
maneuver through objects in the
environment where the breach out of the
water and do flips and you can get fish
to follow you and again this sounds like
kind of silly but it's actually like
really enjoyable and it again it fits
with sort of the peaceful nature of the
game but it gives it a little more
energy and a little more kind of fun and
active and you know it gives the game
some gameplay to fall back on yeah can
you talk about the did mention in your
review the the score by Austin winter
you think you said it like it adapts to
the actual what's happening yeah so
what's what's really cool is I mean
again it's a linear game so as you move
forward you can kind of at least when I
started paying attention to it I
realized that it's not like oh I'm in
area a therefore song a plays and then I
went to area be so song be started it's
more like
as you move the music will adapt to like
sort of where you are and what you're
doing and it seems to do that on the fly
like it's so subtle you don't even
really notice it's just they're adding
this kind of like emotional texture
under current underneath the experience
and it doesn't ever really call
attention to itself it just dynamically
shifts and adjusts and stitches itself
together in these different ways to
provide that that texture to like propel
you through the experience and keep you
in a particular mood that matches
whatever is happening around you it's
like so elegantly done it's yeah you
don't even really notice unless you're
really paying attention yeah the
momentum its specific parts you know you
get into these faster paced parts the
momentum of the score parallels that of
the gameplay and whatnot which is a
really nice feeling because then after a
while you have like these schools of
fish swimming along with you you have
these like big clouds of fish that you
go through you there's no there's one
part yeah I don't want to spoil it there
are there there are specific moments
that like I was talking to people about
and I was saying this part was great and
like I told Mary the same thing about
certain parts so there are memorable
moments in this game it strikes me as
this singular experience someone
something we were all curious about and
uh dodsworth and seven in the twitch
chat had asked if there was multiplayer
I came to journey's or is this just
strictly single player no no it's a
purely purely single player um yeah and
in a way when you when you play the game
you understand why again that this one
of the frustrations about the game that
like you don't want it to vote too much
about it but it is the kind of game
that's best enjoyed on your own just
like put on headphones sit by yourself
just like chill out and play this game
and just let it let it kind of wash over
you man hmm I don't want to get to like
hippy Zen about it because that's not
that's not really who I am but I still
found this game like really cathartic
and just calming and beautiful and just
like exactly what I think a lot of
people might need it's like an amazing
palate cleanser between games like I
don't know overwatch or something really
competitive really high stakes like it's
it's something really great to like just
go do this instead yeah and it's way
looks like I think my current like habit
of playing games right now maybe if i'm
reviewing stuff i'll play something for
about two hours and get up for like ten
minutes if I need to or you know like
just maybe like fun but if it's the
weekend I'll play for two hours go and
do something come back and finish
something off later this is like the
perfect length for me to just sit down
one sitting literally
getting up and uh like Jake and I both
played last night and we talked about it
afterward but that was a thing I didn't
even want to stop playing because it
wasn't it wasn't like pulling me thru at
a breakneck pace but it was the same
time just such a calming thing and like
you said it's just what I needed I just
be doomed the weekend before I've been
playing over watch these fast-paced kind
of just like hella shooters and then
like that's why I was kind of excited
about it because I love journey I loved
you know like gone home I'm excited for
Tacoma fulbright companies other game
coming out I don't know Jake what did
you think about like abs ooh overall
like did it line up with your
expectations of what it was going to be
or without spoiling anything obviously
did it become something altogether new I
actually didn't really have expectations
what I knew about this game and I knew
it had a lot to do with old people who
are people who worked on journey but I
mean I then I heard Pete talk about it
then I heard you talk about it I was
like all right I'm gonna play this game
and i did and i thought it was
phenomenal i think what i have to say is
that if you're deciding between batman
or ab 0 I'd get ab 0 yeah it's nice that
they're both kind of like bite size but
um absolu I think did encompass like a
little broader thing you know without
sounding too pompous and artistic about
it there are like deeper things you can
glean from it whether you want to or not
if you don't want to it's just a it's
just a very fluid fun thing to do like I
know I've like I kind of waited into the
comments on accident and like I was just
yeah yeah it's one of those one of those
things for people saying it's not a game
yeah it's this it's so joyless which is
not an arguing I want to bring up the
weather these are games argument right
now those people just bum me out so much
just like if you're not into it that's
fine you don't need to be it's like
there's a whole world like we have dark
souls we have over watched we have fury
we have a head Lander we have all these
games that either are explicitly trying
to be old games or like the modern
equivalent of those games and are
challenging and skillful like all that
stuff is amazing just let this exists as
well like we have room for all this
stuff like chill out guys it's a
beautiful experience if you don't want
that totally cool you don't need to be
like a joyless jerk and try to ruin it
for everybody else that's all I'll say
and I don't want you to do it I'm sorry
I just had a whole morning of like
people being angry in the comments oh no
shaking my head and getting depressed
yeah I'm sorry bring that up
it's available with these types of games
people will always want to have that
conversation this isn't a game and it's
just it's exhausting every time it's
just shirking those definitions can help
us create more for the media my thinking
but again that's a different argument
and kinda I don't want to get into it
right now I don't think anybody wants to
see it into it what were you say that
maybe I shouldn't said I was gonna say
no we don't i don't care go for it oh I
I mean if it plays so well like you play
us so well like I feel like in the game
that the argument should be over after
that because like the swimming unlike
what Mike was saying like I my least
favorite thing in games is swimming
usually like the minute I dive
underwater I'm like great here we go but
this like the entire experience just
like the swimming just feels so
streamlined so great and like breaching
up out of the water and one it's
exhilarating oh actually one small thing
did you guys figure out the boost
mechanic like the triple boost yeah okay
cuz like I wasn't paying attention they
told me so I just kept like furiously is
happening but if you do the tempo the
123 he does the the kick and then the
mermaid and then the just pull on boost
which is like it feels in flippers yeah
one thing I didn't figure out that Rob
handler we found out was you can do
cannonballs like if you breach out of
the water and hit the circle button you
know I like totally animal is also there
like I saw him doing is how are you
doing that I thought that was really
cool yeah yeah there's all kinds of like
little just nuances and worked into the
mechanics they're really important but
like it's cool that they're there yeah
do either you feel the need to go back
or like do you want to God yeah I
already did I already went back and like
played halfway through it again okay
yeah I'm gonna play this weekend I think
again yeah for me I fully expect this to
be one of those games that I play like
once a year like I just want to go back
to that world and spend time okay yeah I
think I'm kind of differ from you guys
and it was a time and place thing for me
like my lights were off last night I'd
it was just a long day and I just
finished it and it was that's all I need
it's not that I don't like it at all i
really like it i completely agree you
gave it a nine out of ten you know like
we were talking like what should a score
be but after a while it's one of those
games it's hard to assign a score but I
completely get it it's gonna be
different for everybody for me or just
one thing I wanted to just get out the
music was great the the art was great
the actual like way you move through it
in the way it kind of tells it's weird
like simplistic story again without
going to spoilers but it does go into
unlike territory might not expect or
maybe you do I don't know depending on
your kind of what you're expecting a
guess which that's always difficult to
balance with what it really is but yeah
it was a surprise for me
yeah I probably won't go back to like I
said but I really enjoyed like that bite
size experience I think it was just what
I need I think it's like you said what a
lot of people need right now yeah I
would hope that people just give it a
chance I think people will be very
surprised at how it affects them like
just affects their move it affects their
emotions it's just that kind of game
that will get in your head and like the
best way and just kind of wash over you
and like other things just stopped
mattering it really is just like
meditation in Game form and it's
beautiful I sincerely recommend
everybody try it cool yeah me too I
think Jake you could probably support
that and then Mary I don't know if Rob
liked it I think she did you see me seem
to be enjoying it i don't know that he
beat it but he seemed to be enjoying it
when I when I walked over and he was
playing cool well that's absa you can
read scott Butterworth's review it's a 9
out of 10 on games Paco delve into the
minutia on our website and let us know
what you think in the comments below
anyway guys I'm gonna have to kick both
you all I heard the door open all right
yeah game over gonna get a couple new
people on Pete Brown coming on and Jimmy
is gonna come on to tell us about the
axis better Mike don't ruin the podcast
I'll try not to have a good day guys
I'll probably see you in like half an
hour oh man there's Pete Brown a show
regular with a beard far better than
mine ever will be what do you use for
that time time i've been using curry and
it didn't work I just smell really weird
the rest of the day you just gotta let
your beard grow out yeah yeah I feel
like you don't try yours is much better
than mine anyway I know I guess I can't
go my too much maybe like rub me all on
my chance it promotes growth may be like
when I hit 30 i'll start growing a beard
more yeah and a year time that's at i'm
not kidding like all my siblings that
work 28 before they start going beer so
not 30 being facetious but anyway this
is run its course every time you come on
the show it's just gets deeper the beard
guest Jimmy how you doing what he
brought to today i'm doing alright i
just finished the review on this one
guys can sweet see it yeah that's what
we're talking about yeah xbox one s I
don't know which camera should probably
one of those two that's good yeah so I
just reviewed this this morning rather
the NDA just lifted this morning yeah
let's get into that we are going to be
talking about the xbox one s which what
is it like publicly
today okay cool so I could get one if I
wanted to but there's one right here so
I'm going to take this afterward but
anyway people are like curious about
this because a like you know like the
Scorpio is also announced and right now
that's the working title I don't know
that such as final name yeah product
Scorpio the xbox one launched with a few
problems and everything like hardware
wise it's kind of always it was always
up for a discussion on a variety of
fronts but I guess people are curious
about this I guess the overarching
question which we can get into later
after we talked about the specs and
what's new with it and what it does for
people who might have an xbox the organ
question being is it worth getting with
the Scorpio on the horizon yeah just
jump right in there I guess what's your
yeah I mean it really depends on where
you're coming from so I would say if you
have an xbox one already then don't
upgrade to this unless you really want
the HDR and 4k support so this xbox can
do HD or 4k video streaming so yeah I
wouldn't upgrade if you already have an
xbox one if you do you know want that
you know those media features then this
thing is as far as I'm concerned a
must-buy it's actually cheaper than like
dedicated players out there yeah and it
comes with an xbox one yeah well that
was a thing like what it's got like what
4k blu-ray the HDR which like HDR is
like high dynamic range but basically a
lot more contrast right yeah more
contrast it's a higher color gamut as
well yeah so yeah I remember you saying
like in the review that like the black
pixels almost look like they're not even
lit up at all right hurts like you know
like ideally um but and that's like
supposedly the next big thing apart from
4k like four times the resolution or
whatever really yeah I think it's
actually in my opinion it's probably a
bigger difference you know HDR is a
bigger difference than 1080p 24 k
upgrade mmm um the colors are just
really much more vibrant yeah Sookie
tell us about like obviously it's forty
percent smaller I've heard it's pretty
heavy for its apparently it isn't
exactly forty percent smaller I don't
know what the exact percentage is but if
you consider like the fact that it has
integrated power brick it's actually
it's actually like really impressively
small because the power brick on the
original xbox was massive there's no
good place to put that thing ever like a
behind like an entertainment center just
bury it under dirty clothes
and pray it catches fire yeah you close
you don't want yes so the power brick is
like back here I believe it's a lot
smaller this time around okay it's a
little bit more power efficient and it's
like can tell me about the specs I'm I'm
very I'm gonna leave this to YouTube's
i'm done with the specs are largely the
same still has a AMD a core processor i
think it's clogged i like 1.7 gigahertz
the GPU is actually has been it's it's a
little faster this time around it's i
think it's up from like 153 megahertz to
like 914 not a lot it's a seven percent
boost and while some games can benefit
slightly from this it's going to be
pretty hard to notice it's mostly for
the performance boost is mostly for HDR
support okay can that someone's asking
the twitch can this stand vertically
just like any other console or it can I
don't have the standing right now but it
can without it it's just it's sort of
like the pay station where it can stand
vertically but um good this way are you
guys vertical standards or horizontal I
always want to be a vertical standard
huh you know like I think about it I'm
like yeah I could be that guy vertically
like me up right is the aspirational
poised pose for your xbox and poise and
poise yeah but I never managed to like
get the stands find a way to arrange it
it's just I think most media centers are
more geared towards like a horizontal
kind of set up anyhow unless you're
gonna put it on top of the table just
rotate these degrees oh there you go
that guy the TV's gonna be like super
high up on the side all right so there
are updates right out of the gate
obviously um I was reading it they take
up 400 gigs is that correct or between
the OS and updates yes so this put this
down at work sure yeah the gearing do
live in California where those
earthquakes um yeah so this is the two
terabyte version I wanted to see you
know after the OS updates and the
firmware and all that stuff you know how
much space would I have you know to pay
wrong with and it was 1.6 mm terabytes
so that means they essentially 400 so
but that raises a question then if you
buy the 500 gigabyte version you're only
going to have one hundred gigabytes so I
asked Microsoft this actually and they
basically kind of gave me a non-answer
man screw that that's a change that's a
real serious question that people need
answer no I definitely answered them and
they deal I know I know yeah they didn't
I didn't answer is good that's I can't I
can't verify that because what's it was
like he was saying something with um
like there's something to do with like
the summer sale like taking up some I
don't know he was sanctioned just
somewhat summer sale on his answer so
seasonally your Xbox may have what was
the what was like the baseline xbox one
storage when it first came out 500 oh
yeah you after everything else
downloaded no no after uh don't need the
xbox one I don't remember yeah okay yeah
um how is just like your experience been
like performance-wise playing games did
you like did you get a lot of time
playing games that at all yeah so I
played a about a half dozen games or
slow I mean it's you know it is seven
percent faster but a lot of games are
actually they actually use like locked
frame rates like for instance if if
you're playing a game and it's like
locked at 30 frames per second well just
because it gets you know seven percent
faster it's still locked at 30 so you're
not going to see any difference so if a
game doesn't feature a lock frame rate
then theoretically you can so but like
being able to tell the difference is
gonna be really hard did you like in
general kind of I don't know did can
certain games in certain cases perform
actually better on this member reports
came out june that like there are
certain specs with this yeah what about
if there are games that don't have
unlocked frame rates then theoretically
yes okay and get up to a seven percent i
was curious with this releasing like
whether this would tell us anything
about the Scorpio which is still largely
like some of its under wraps I don't
think we're this is indicative of
anything because it's such a minor
upgrade over the xbox one right yeah
aside from the actual physical sense
honestly I feel like the performance
difference is you're gonna see like it's
not really a selling point for the
console you shouldn't buy this because
it's going to be maybe seven percent I
mean so it's it's maybe seven percent
faster but like a video card you can
overclock that to be like fifteen
percent faster so like that's mean it's
not a huge thing just yeah spective I
mean I wonder how much this is just I
mean obviously she's filling the gap
before the Scorpio comes out because
we're getting into those sure you know
but
like the more of a pc life cycle for a
console it's not like just gonna be an
xbox one xbox to anymore yeah and i want
anyone could see like s for every
generation sort of like the iphone oh
yeah i'm wondering like if it's this how
much of this was a reaction to like PS
4.5 or whatever to fill that gap and
kind of compete still and especially the
NX being and coming out in the spring
supposedly maybe just microsoft was
trying to fill that it's a real easy way
to renew interest in their console a
console that hasn't been selling as well
as the competition yeah you know hey
here's a new version it's sleeker it's
sexier it's no longer this big hulking
thing and yet maybe it's a little bit
faster and maybe you get some more media
stuff with it as well yeah like that
might tip some people over the edge
mm-hmm and make microsoft look like they
understand the problems with the
original xbox one and are improving it
yeah because there's like apart from the
actual hardware there's nothing else
like they're not like updating any it's
going to be just if you turn it on it's
gonna seem like an Xbox one experience
right apart from minor yeah instances
that doesn't have a connect port though
so you'll need a like a USB adapter food
which is a bummer well I'm never getting
escape there are few get calls man
that's true yeah there are people though
who I think maybe do use the voice
commands mm-hmm but you don't have to
trade in your xbox one if you already do
that you've already got one yeah
probably need to worry about it do
either of you like aside from the fact
that you're reviewing it for work plan
on getting one um I'm currently
borrowing an xbox one from work and the
idea of owning this sounds good to me
the idea of spending money on it does
not yeah because the Scorpio is looming
right so I don't know yeah I'm attracted
to it but I'm not jumping at it yeah i
mean i think my my desk space is like
it's pretty full right now and I to be
honest I mostly play I play on pc but i
do think it is the the best and sexiest
xbox there is and is weird cuz i called
it sexy in the review in the comments
are like how can you call inanimate
think sexy was like a Lamborghini can be
guys sexy don't know how can you be a
jerk on the internet comment like that a
plethora of ways yes yeah so i guess i
don't know is there anything else you
should know expects wising you covered
it like whether i get the big question
being like if it's worth getting in the
gap which you were saying it's kind of
been a strange it's in a very strange
space because i don't think we've ever
encountered
a new system refresh with the company
announcing a new next-gen console before
or at least I can't well they all in a
scenario they showed the Refresh of the
xbox 360 when they announced the xbox
one they came out with an even slimmer
version of the xbox Suzy ok there are
like three or four versions of but I
mean you gotta remember the Scorpio is
gonna be really expensive yeah and maybe
even come out and said like that's good
pricey so you know I think about in
those terms right like if you want to be
a part of the xbox ecosystem and it's
gonna be backwards compatible exactly so
yeah do you think like Sony and
Microsoft released the xbox one and ps4
knowing that the life cycle would become
like this surge that's just very much
adapting on the fly to what PC like are
now I mean when they shipped it to the
architecture that is no longer like semi
custom chips and they're sort of I guess
they are maybe a little semi cos I mean
their customized yeah but you know you
don't even like the their x86 it's not
like they're making like yeah like weird
power pc chips anymore that's
interesting question I actually kind of
wrote an article that touches upon that
I think it I mean you'd have to ask them
but like going to an x86 architecture
which is the same architecture to that
computers use pcs use it opens the door
so maybe they kind of had that in mind I
don't know if like you know prix 2013
before these consoles were out and these
consoles were designed you know much
earlier than that i don't know if they
had no concrete plans just yet but i
think it was just like if we wanted to
we probably could yeah so yeah i don't
know i personally am probably i'm gonna
hold off on this i have an xbox one I've
been you I use I'm dare you is so six
I'd it does look really good in it like
just it also just seems like it would
fit better in the space i have as
opposed to that vcr player of a council
that i use now and then again i bring
this up all the time denoise me that
much but my roommate Jake Decker has the
loudest xbox one ever so I might buy one
for him so I have to deal with that
thing anymore we're like jerk dicker
jerk decker yeah his xbox is low that's
one its fan is like playing maracas when
it spins around I don't know how else to
describe it without like actually being
like I don't know the technical terms
what having some to grow courtesy
maracas technical terms oh I have no
idea but anyway yeah that is the xbox
one s you can read the full review on
games by
now Jimmy wrote it overall maybe hold
off you want to Scorpio if you don't
have an xbox one go for this it's
smaller it's kind of a similar
experience but yet let us know you think
I just know if you think you're gonna
get one let us know you think if you
might hold off like I will for the
Scorpio in the comments below thanks so
much Jimmy I'm gonna have to boo you off
thanks for having me leave the xbox
anyway yeah we're gonna get Alex new
house on who's been patiently waiting
I'm sure no we're gonna be talking about
something that people probably people
somehow are not sick of talking about
anymore my sky damn it you can't have it
you can't have it yeah it's a nice segue
we're gonna be talking about no man's
sky and Alex you wrote something kind of
got a lot of us thinking or kind of
exaggerating out it didn't really get
ready no I'm kidding I'm mr. I'm honey
what why can't you sleep I just wrote
this thinking I don't know what to think
of it yeah I actually saw you reading it
you just turn the only thing you said to
me was oh you've got a typo let me fix
you spell mechanic like mech Nick Nick
if i recall click click uh anyway um
yeah so no mass guy it's out in what a
week from today I'll just ate August
what is today knife wait a second you're
a second oh my god it's almost here I'm
supposed to be you're off to Europe yeah
yeah that's next week your ass yes yeah
but yeah so nice guy we've talked about
a lot but one of the looming questions
is like always kind of what we'll be
doing in it for a minute to minute and
we've kind of talked about that over a
few times like there's an economy to a
league trying to improve your technology
to reach the center of universe after 30
or 40 something hours that one guy who
bought it ahead of time I think it took
him 35 I don't know if there's no that
he actually did it but yeah I'm his word
Mike yeah his word which you keep a good
segue is that we're going to talk about
the morality of no man's sky like
basically are you gonna be good or bad
right because there are choices like
when I first found out that you could be
like a space pirate like hell yes let me
throw out like put a parrot on my
shoulder and just zoom around the galaxy
hijacking people stealing people's stuff
yeah like yeah boarding the mainframe
I'm trying to think of like what like
futuristic
pirates would be doing would the parrot
also be futuristic yeah he's robotic a
cyborg pair okay so a spirit I feel much
better about this whole thing I was
worried for his well-being at that
pretty sure parents can't live in space
so you know it's a vacuum up there yeah
but basically it sound like it's such a
big universe right like where the odds
of us actually running into another
person's ago I one in a hundred thousand
hey isn't that right even its weight
lower than that oh really from the math
I did it could be different than they
they could be doing some trickery to get
people in with you but it's like I want
I did the math and to have a one-percent
chance of any two people being on the
same planet you would have to have like
300 million people playing at the same
time so that's like miniscule chance the
old rose not even 300 million people on
earth she's saying I should play the
lotto instead of trying to find someone
else in no man's sky exactly I'm waiting
for that one comment that actually
thinks I was serious someone thought I
was shares my thought the Eiffel Towers
in Germany baby insulting the American
education system I don't know where
they're from but I guess probably france
a sense of you so yeah but they're there
are more than I think there are more
than 300 people in the world but with
that big of a universe and like this may
like the plethora of ways you could
spend your time or is it gonna be like
Grand Theft Auto where you're just using
it as a power fantasy and kind of except
like getting some inner rage out or are
you gonna be trying to actually preserve
it and like be a good person like you
might in mass effect like a Paragon
route right and i think the probably one
of the most interesting parts of this is
that they say that the Universe to an
extent is going to be permanent so you
can screw up a planet bad enough that
it's saved to the server and there's
like I really can't think of another
game that is like that that has a
universe that persistent um that is
shared among you know many players
minecraft I mean you can also just
restart this like make another server
though right like not if you believe in
that one server you play minecraft ism
one server dude just that's it that's it
what sir Brown yeah because that's I
don't I still don't even understand
fully I understand aren't like how the
algorithm works for them to create this
universe I don't get how that's going to
work in retrospect and save everything
but at what point do you actually just
start caring about this universe when
it's so massive and how do you feel like
you're making an impact and then that
was your question if you don't feel like
you're making an impact why would you be
good right and if the only way you can
make an impact is by you know blowing up
half a planet then you know is that
something that we want to do yes no like
I i I've told people like my intent I've
expressed my intentions if I can create
some sort of Death Star I will in real
life yeah my maniacal intentions are
getting megamo megalomaniacal giggle
let's go there yeah into space I'm just
gonna destroy Jupiter has been eyeing me
lately I'm not having it it's the
biggest planet I gotta take it down
bullying everyone else I think the
biggest one yeah it's not even in our
solar system how many planets what okay
anywhere um but yeah like what what's to
stop someone from just playing like
Grand Theft Auto like I would and at a
certain point how're is it actually
gonna affect the universe are so many
unknowns with this game because it's so
big it's hard to wrap our minds around
lates it's a galaxy right now the
universe right and I mean like it is a
game right like it's fine for people to
have fun and go blow stuff up but i
think the the thing that makes this more
complicated is there are creatures in
this universe that only exists on like
one in a hundred million planets like
they're each creature you come across is
procedurally generated but there but
there are levels of uniqueness and
interest like there are more interesting
characters than others like you or
creatures than others you will come
across utopian civilizations may be and
what if a person rolls up to one of
these utopian civilizations to decide
that it's sighing him wrong yeah and
just blows it up yeah save to the server
two things how awesome would be if you
come across a planet with humans or some
similar intelligent sentient life and be
how much would that affect your like
your moral compass because if I'm just
gonna destroy this four-legged thing and
every all of its family members in its
planet I don't I don't care no I'll
probably like I'm a carnivore I'll eat
it and I'm not a vegetarian or vegan in
real life my character is gonna be a
vegan space pirate in disguise oh that's
different but yeah if you come across
like how do you actually care about
these animals if like a they're just
animals but also be this is like
no one else in the world sees this
animal except for you like chances are
hot like us again how does how do you
weigh the population people the number
of people playing the game with like
who's actually else is seeing this yeah
like my personal thoughts on this is
it'll probably be easier for me
personally to preserve creatures or
it'll be more likely that all preserved
creatures who look like humans like who
interacts with me in a certain way that
is human-like kid the biggest threat
yeah that is true yeah take him down I
would love if we got the senator
universe and just like punish the people
who were bad yeah it'd be awesome what
do you how do you plan on playing this
game I like to think that I'll just be
as you all just going around you know
making sure we're keeping track of
things that I see that are cool but i'm
probably going to end up you know blown
up space stations and rolling around as
a space pirate make sure pop you have I
you I really want to do a lot of flight
an exploration like in the you know the
outer space I don't think I'll be able
to do a lot of that because I'm also
reviewing this game there's a lot to do
I'm terrified reviewing this game mm-hmm
but uh yeah I don't I guess I don't put
too much stock into how I'm going to
feel about the decisions I make in
regards to affecting life or other
people but we'll see if it'll shift yeah
I plan on like I said be in bed I'm just
gonna jump it like San Andreas and kind
of mess stuff up which it just begs a
question like how good do I think the
rest of the universe is and how much
punishment do I think it deserves from
my standpoint from my solipsistic
standpoint as a planet destroying vegan
space pirate with a robotic parrot I've
already got this all figured out the
know me like I uses name what's the name
the universe has original sin you have
to punish it for its original sin uh
sorry your name thing derailed me
captain cyber jim g ym no no no like no
I know like you know g ym yeah she's
gonna be ripped yeah ripped a vegan
space pirate um no like that's how
there's so many unknowns this game like
again I it's huge but how do we actually
look at it how do we say like how do we
like affect this world when were that
big and I guess that's
kind of affecting because san andreas
and los santos or like these like these
actual contain environments that you can
see how you're you don't really affect
the world and grant the thought but like
in mass effect that's uh there's a fair
number of planets you can explore it's
not this like the scope of no man's sky
but you're actually still you know
certain people won't make it to Mass
Effect 3 certain people won't even make
it through to how do you make those
decisions because it's a smaller cast
you actually care about them in this I
just feel like I'm not going to care
about anybody because I know they're
they might be expendable because there's
not that much substance like and I
haven't played the game very few people
have but how do I can affect my
decisions I don't know it might all feel
meaningless yeah and I think there's a
strange balancing act there between what
the developers trying to do to make the
world the world's that many many worlds
matter but also just the sheer immensity
of the of the universe like you're you
guys were saying how do you make this
stuff matter how do you why would you
ever care about one animal that you come
across on it on a planet when there are
you know an uncountable number of
animals on other planets yeah i mean the
begs a question like is any of this
there's any existence or any of this
matter how do you make a game that big
and actually find meaning in it that's
like I think that's why everybody so
curious but no man's sky because um like
if I could explore the universe I
probably wouldn't care about like you
too what no you know I wouldn't blame
you i'd be good I'd be happy to see you
go honestly close friends are only like
a matter of relativity yes like a more
you travel in the more you explore the
last minute I'm gonna text you guys and
see how you're feeling unless I'm gonna
open up to you but snapchat still
nothing yeah step off to us now me and I
don't have a name for the parrot yet
either obviously better at this in a
Groucho there you go alright Jim and
Groucho captain cyber gym and Groucho
yeah it's gonna be a matter of yeah
substance how do you find that in this
world as their substance to be found at
a certain point there's the size of a
kind of Trump yeah the meaning you find
in it do you guys care about getting to
the center of the universe no no if you
maybe the game will make me care I mean
yeah like yeah what I understand is like
are you never interrupted by like a an
event that kind of prods you'd to like
you want to do one thing or another
like that's what I really want to know
if this is just like just go do whatever
that's gonna be super hard for me to
like feel great about continuing to do
you know to do because if I'm not
working towards something and if that
something is only getting to the center
of the galaxy Thanks have you read
anything about what the weaker has been
saying not really I only looked at one
of his game play clothes so I was about
a half hour long and i clicked around it
and minute to minute he was doing the
exact same thing yeah just pointing his
laser at rocks he has he didn't spoil
anything but he did say that there is a
little bit of that at least this sort of
direction yeah we feel like there has to
be yeah there has to be right well the
reason I want to play no man's sky is
the same reason I played like Skyrim for
so long it was that just exploring this
world but that even that that was a
contained world's a singular experience
but there are like story threads going
through it where is it doesn't seem like
that's gonna happen here the stories you
find are the ones you create yourself
which is very appealing well I don't
know that that's how I'm digging right
now it's just such a weird case and I'm
I'm excited for it to release just so we
can like know what the hell it is like
and I come in and ask about it he just
has exact same conversation on the giant
bombcast that's like that's what it
boils down to be I just want to know
what it is it's curiosity at this right
yeah if it's great then awesome I'd
maybe will be if it's not then I don't
know it's just been you know like it's
been hiked a lot because it's such a
weird it could be like like a new
benchmark for how things like this are
created but how much is there gonna be
like how longevity and you know reaching
the center of universe like might be the
goal but is it worth taking the time to
get through yeah I mean in something
that I've been saying since it was
announced is if it was Proteus in space
and they positioned it as such I would
be totally into it but they've been
hiding this game up and talking about it
and trying to put to rest the whole the
questions about his gameplay and stuff
that I think that for one thing they'll
never be able to fulfill expectations
for this and for another I think they've
gone like they they just stopped
stressing the discovery aspect of it
yeah so I don't know yeah well anyway
this is officially I think the last time
we're going to talk about no man's sky
on the lobby before it's outright what
comes out tuesday but i don't think
reviews are going to be up then it's
it's so doubtful yeah okay well likely
aside from like
when we get to talk to you about the
review I think this is the last time we
have to fit no man's sky into it which
is nice I feel like I kind of want like
I really want to get into this game like
I need an outfit to wear when I'm
playing it so I can be cyber gym a
snuggie Oh like Oh robust I thought you
meant something comfortable like a
catheter and a snuggie in no okay no six
pack of high knees no takata is yeah I
mean I'm zorno it all has the hybrid
cyber gym and Groucho super in one if
you're not you're not even doing it
right but anyway a holy crap that is no
man's sky will you be good or bad let us
know in the comments below the game
comes out next week finally depending on
when you're watching this video if
you're watching alive then yeah next
week we'll talk about it more on the
lobby when we finally get to review it
but uh yeah yeah anyway what do you guys
well I shoot I gotta bring back this up
yeah to get back to the giveaway yarny
follow gamespot so we can DM you there
was a tweet that went up at two-fifteen
from gamespot about yarny if you win you
will get this adorable thing i'm gonna
try to set it there i don't think it'll
work or woman boy he's got his i just
dropped his tail give me a second he's
got a tail as well it comes with it
which is I don't you know like the game
you unravel him unraveled it's the name
of the game but yeah we will d mu the
code for let us know if you want ps4
xbox one and we'll get it to you oh yeah
tell me the show what you guys doing
this weekend it's Tuesday why I'm asking
better I'm looking ahead well oh well I
have I have a music festival outside
lands I'm gonna see Radiohead we see
Lionel Richie tight nice st. Lucia Sam
FIFA mill I'm familial with them what
are your plans this week the rest this
week I'm taking tomorrow off I'm go to
the Stanley Kubrick exhibit over at the
Jewish history museum mm-hmm gonna go
have brunch with my girlfriend's grandma
nice probably some bacon mmm maybe fruit
nice I hear Mary laughing Mary's
marriage enjoying this never not
laughing I don't know i get my life is
boring crops you doing you're young
you're interesting yeah my girlfriend
works at the Jewish Museum you should a
tomorrow she's working there you should
say hi well hot damn what's your game
I'll be oh I can I like like freaked her
out and ya know her hey you met her he
would
school together no don't even say that
just go up and hug her and pretend you
just saw her like the day before Kirsten
Kirsten Kirsten yeah where's your to
Rick fan why does she work the nope yep
why the hell does she work at the way
what she thinks we're gonna on the
Kiryat curatorial staff there we go mmm
so I'll ask for the head curator yeah
I'm there that's her basically yep tight
sweet I already curated real that sounds
so stupid don't tell don't tell
something gonna curate them oh by the
way don't like those shoes I don't like
that hat so I'm gonna put them on
display is that what curating yeah yeah
by the way their ice cream sandwiches in
the lobby you guys should go get them
right now yeah at the Jewish history
museum why would I go all the way over
there got there Mike okay anyway yeah
sweet the show was like on track until
like you two came on at least I'd like
to think it was but yeah anyway so
that's the end of our show today Danny
O'Dwyer will be back next week I think
what he say the Batman oh yeah sorry i
forgot to tease this thing uh we're
doing a batman the game we talked about
earlier the tell-tale Batman the
tell-tale series episode one realm of
shadows stream I believe it with Jake
Decker and Mary Kish kind of like going
through it as well yeah thank you Eric
teh everybody shot to Marrakech Jean
Luc's psyche and everybody else in back
Eric taser right now for putting on the
show sadly this is my last week hosting
for a while Danny's back from again I
still don't know where he's been this is
just the mystery in itself he's probably
a in Iceland let's not tell him let's
not tell him yeah was he in Ireland I
said let's not tell him the land of my
ancestors I'm my McGrath enough all
right anyway thank you all for joining
uh you know like we'll see you next week
Daniel be back and hopefully that he can
end the show better than I can thanks
for joining everybody